okay thank you I hope you can hear me
all right and as was set i'm talking
about building industrial applications
and i'm replacing like my my colleagues
different Brown who was originally
supposed to hold it so I am I only
slightly changed his slides and I think
that will hopefully go go all right so
the questions is the question that you
have to answer often when you were
offering Mathematica as a consultant in
industries is Mathematica fit for
developing and deploying real world
applications in an industrial
environment and that has some
implications that are probably known to
some of you but probably not to all and
I'm trying to just show you some of the
implications that that environment has I
want to first show you a few slides
about smarty the company that I work for
who we are what we do and why I think I
have something to contribute about that
topic and then I will have a few words
about Mathematica from a from the view
of a developer and i will also define
what I I think a developer is in that
respect and then I have been an example
where show how industrial application in
the sense that we understand it is
different from usual mathematical
notebook
and work that you're doing in science or
in in other areas and then finding us
some conclusions and i hope i can at
least partially answer the question that
this is on the top of that slide so
smart is more company cjd munich we are
for physicists and one engineer and he
brings us back to the roots sometimes
and we are using mathematica as one of
our main tools it's not the only one we
are driven by our customers so if they
want us to use something else we use
something else but if you have the
choice we often choose Mathematica and I
think for good reasons and I try to
explain why and we are specialized in
building customized software solutions
for engineering applications and we have
a long experience my my colleague Stefan
the founder of the company is doing this
for more than 20 years now I myself do
it for about 15 years and we have done
more than 20 50 projects and in in in
these years so there is some experience
and we have seen quite a lot of the
evolvement of Mathematica in the process
and yeah so probably it's interesting to
share some of our experiences and well
it's probably also industrial
applications can mean a lot of things
and for us it's typically because we're
a small team and and and we are that's
where we good at we provide inexpensive
easy to install solutions which are
ordered and paid from the speciality
departments not it's not we're not so
good at having big PowerPoint things to
to get an enterprise-wide a big project
but we are pretty good at getting this
small things done and that's typically
in the order of half a year man year
projects and and we deliver a working
solution which just helps them do that
rock and I've been asked what smart cie
is why we call ourselves like that
and I had to explain that we are not
thinking that other people are doing
dumped CAE but it's supposed to to prove
force calculations and if you're in the
engineering world you you basically have
to kind of approaches one is rule of
thumb plus a factor to for safety and
maybe you have some external files that
no one understands and then on the other
hand you have a hundred million element
finite element solutions which run on a
big cluster and and and sometimes crazy
and and they are great and but sometimes
they don't even give you the answers you
want so I think there is a gap in
between those two extremes and and we
were trying to fill that okay that is
something where i would say typically
industries the real message of this
slide is there is no tepidly industry
for us we are in very different
customers from from different branches
and that's just what the top top six but
we have done other things and even this
list this is not really giving you
probably a pattern it's it's similar to
two typical applications we do all kinds
of engineering physics Applied Physics
that's heat transfer production
processes but it's also data analysis if
our customer needs that sometimes these
are things are mixed actually heat
transfers usually make the mixed in
thing because heat as its own is not
really a problem and not not very
difficult to solve but it usually comes
not alone but you have other effects
radiation you have any kind of electro
heat and and usually the combination
that's difficult and it's it's other the
combinations that is not always
straightforward to solve its existing
standard solutions
so I was mentioning that I'm trying to
give you the picture of mathematica from
the view point of view of a developer of
a professional developer of mathematical
based applications in the industrial
environment that's a long sentence and I
try to explain what I mean with with all
these words professional means you have
a limited budget you have time
constraints and and you always have to
keep in mind that development
maintenance support all have a cost so
with mathematical you usually very fast
and developing but you have to take care
that that advantage is not eaten up by
additional efforts for maintenance and
and and and support later on so that's
things that probably are different when
you would write your code for your own
research work then it's great you've got
your result you publish your result and
the topic is finished but if you deliver
code to others then you have to maintain
you have to fix bugs and that makes it
different and then another day big
differences that you work in a team
usually and then sets something that is
a big difference if you write code and
it's not your code it's it's it's shared
among the developers and if and and it's
really a learning curve for everyone who
starts working in an area who comes from
a university that this is not your code
and it is good that it is not your code
because if you are on holiday and the
customer complains about the back you're
quite happy that your colleague can can
fix it it's a different thing and people
have to learn it and it makes also it
has many consequences like you're using
a version control system you you can't
go without one if you work in a team
that means notebooks are not really
well-suited for that so you switch to
de-emphasis really little practical
things that are influenced by such
differences developer is already said to
someone who writes code mainly for the
others to use it's not that you write
code for you to use and then you share
it it's really it's you're probably not
even interested in running it runs on
your machine you're writing it for
someone else and it is their ideas and
their demands that you have to fulfill
it's also a big difference and probably
not everyday situation for for typical
mathematica uses IC and an application
compared to a package is something that
runs and the users not necessarily
himself mathematica users so he has no
knowledge about it it just it doesn't
care in what language you have provided
your your application it just wants it
to to work and to be easy to use then
industrial is a wide field I have just
written some things here you usually
have to handle a full set of parameters
it's not enough to just concentrate on
the parameters that are interesting in
the problem but you have to provide of
possibilities to give the full set and
you have to incorporate measured and
real-world data which often is large
because people don't I mean they don't
care if your application has problems if
that's 10,000 points in your
interpolating function they don't they
just have measured that and they want it
to work so you have to you have to
import it you have to to to thin out if
necessary but you have to do that they
wouldn't expect the solution which just
crashes so that's something that often
makes extra and necessary to to have
some extra effort you always want units
these people are engineers and there's
good reason for having units everywhere
then you have naming conventions that
you have to respect and there's also
regulations and requirements that come
from some corporate stuff like you have
to put your data in a certain form
because they want it that way and that's
nothing that you will dis
with your customers okay that is also I
think a big difference then robustness
is something that we are permanently
addressing because they if someone pays
you for writing code he doesn't accept
if it precious they will accept if it
crashes once in a while but the level of
tolerance is very low and that sometimes
needs also extra efforts if you will
provide a mathematical solution and then
you want something that is easy to use
interactive with a graphical user
interface but you also want it to be a
possible to use that code in an
automated way so you can do parametric
studies or optimizations because this
this stuff is not run to to learn
something or to understand the model or
something they want to get answers and
so they can make decisions so that's
also kind of a difference now have a few
more general things about Mathematica I
think it is very well established in
academia it is other established
bachelors in this industry for
prototyping and for a first shoot for
new results to try out a new method
that's where it is really well
established and and in industry you
typically have Mathematica use all with
all over the places but there the tool
as is more known as a personal tool for
the rocket scientist for those people
who do the difficult stuff that no one
else understands and and and and and
many don't understand why it's done at
all so so it's it's it's it's in any way
and it a corner where people often don't
understand what people do and I think
that it's not necessarily the case it
could be different and I've very
simplified history from my own personal
view about the history and the evolution
of mathematic get started to be known as
a
computer algebra system for doing
symbolic stuff and then it from the
beginning had more capabilities in
numerics than then comparative programs
and it soon got really good in many
visualization and that's that is the
scientific platform that we all know and
and we all appreciate and I think in
recent years while research has tried to
push it into a real all-purpose system
in our purpose language and to some
extent I think that is already in a good
shape but we are not completely there
yet and unfortunately I also think that
that the use in industry is not as
common as it probably could be and well
I am NOT in the position to tell you why
it's just a effect and then it's
something that probably could be changed
so so where does a giant I think we have
heard many very interesting and great
talks about new features and we all know
where it were very change I we have that
short I just want to do emphasize that
we use it for a reason we are very happy
with it especially and then I just
couldn't resist to add that to those
dislike this from an engineering point
of view that the numerical differential
equations always are really great I mean
they they are really good and
comparative with everything else that
you can have in the in the market and
there were new things in in version 9
like parametric and ease of and one
events and then now in 10 days finite
element method and to some extent that I
sometimes feel that even it governs
themselves underestimate the power that
that d so fast so thank you for having
having that and I hope especially the
finite element method will make more
progress so it would really fulfills all
that what what you can expect from it so
we also have recently within the last
year seen a lot wide variety of
possibilities to to deploy your
applications we have always had
Mathematica I mean at least ten years or
so we have had boy from playerpro which
is quite interesting part if you try to
sell your a mathematical code because it
is a relatively inexpensive frontin
environment so you can just give your
customer that thing plus your code and
it will run like a complete Mathematica
for only a fraction of the costs there's
CDF which is in a commercial environment
usually at least in the engineering
applications it's missing the
possibility to reach data moment that is
something that you usually need but it's
it's good that it's there and then there
is no cloud and mathematica online I
think there will be some some other
interesting ways to deploy your
applications unfortunately there are
also some dark corners and that's a bit
of a paradox situation for me because
usually I need to convince my customers
that it is it makes sense to use
mathematic as a platform for developing
serious applications now today I'm a bit
in the different corner and and I am
just pointing to some things that if you
ever think about using it for that
purpose that I think you should be aware
of and probably it will also be changed
in future versions one thing that I'm
missing is is an ecosystem that is when
you look at other languages you
typically see how they advertise their
ecosystem like libraries that you can
add automatic installation of off
libraries and all these things like
comprehensive pearl archive made pearl
attractive not so much language but just
this feature and we're missing something
like that I think in mathematica but
there is also an ecosystem and
demonstrations is something that is I
think very well it if you just search
something to see how can I approach a
problem that is new to me then you
certainly will find something there and
mathematica stacks exchanges also
something where you can get high-quality
answers from from from all over the
world so there is some good things but I
think it could be better another thing
I'm missing is the attraction of
developers so usually and I would be
interesting to see if there is an
exception people come from Mathematica
and then they turn to a developer it's
hardly ever that you find someone who is
a developer and juices mathematic as its
language because it just doesn't happen
then yeah it's it's it's just a fact and
well that is something that I think you
would have to work on if you really want
to establish Mathematica as a platform
for for development application
development in a professional
environment just if you try to search a
job post posting where a mathematical
developers search you probably will not
find work worldwide so I think that's
really something that would be nice to
see to change yeah yeah certainly well
or already yeah you and you and me and
honestly some parts of the of the code
are not not robust enough for or hardly
robust enough to really qualify as
industrial strength so
degree functionality if you do something
complexes is really hard to get fluid
and and and robust if you need to get
your stuff to disk and then and then
load it import export that all is there
and it works but if you have big data if
you want it to be fast and you often
find corners where you have to do your
own thing now another thing is the the
wall from work bench I I don't know is
it version 3 out I don't know that's it
i'm waiting i think for eight years that
they update this and that's that would
be a useful tool if you're a developer
and it's just well not on the top of the
priority list then there is no useful
debugger which is something you're
really missing if you come from another
language people who use other languages
always ask me how can she live with the
debugger render when i do project with
other languages i really miss miss a
debugger for about a week I mean I've
learned to go get along with without one
and I think we all have learned to get
along without but this is something that
is missing it especially if you write
complicated dynamic code a debugger
would make your life easy that's also
something from a developer point of view
you would wish to have more control over
the dynamic language I mean it's really
impressive that you just have one liner
and you have an interface that's great
and I don't want to to change that
that's gift success to these
functionalities to people who would
never learn an event-based library for
whatever but if you work as a developer
you you just you just need more control
and if something doesn't work you want
it to work and not to just find a
workaround so that is something that I
saw high on my wishes there are some
other things but I think I leave it at
me the good thing is that
you can do it yourself there's jailing
there's netlink there's library link so
you have all possibilities to coat that
stuff that you're missing and and and
then you get your new stuff done so you
although there are some parts that are
not good enough probably you always can
replace it with something that is
hopefully good enough but it takes
efforts and well it is a kind of
annoyance if there is import for hdf5
format and if i try it it it can do what
i need so i have to program it myself so
thats sometimes also a surprise which
makes you miss your budget so i have
fear just an example and that's heat
transfer which is something that we have
the robot it's not problem not a problem
but it's it's it's an convenient if you
have a packet an application with a 30
which consists of 30 thought empires
some some notebooks or paletta files and
you have to pack all that and you have
to encode it so it runs in and you want
to pack it to something and I probably
show you what we have programmed ourself
our customers are not IT personals over
they want one button to press and
install it and that's something that is
you can do it all in Mathematica but
yeah it's not there okay now this is
from the demonstration page I'm not
really trying to show you anything
interesting it's just to show the
difference I mean this is a really great
things to you can learn a lot and then
play with the parameters but it's it's
kind of limited because some parameters
are missing or you have another one that
one over there does the nonlinear case
when the material
is temperature dependent and material
properties and and the do you won't find
something that would let an engineer do
a layout for a insulation of a
industrial window something because you
would need all the features that this
demonstration combined in one
application and and also that's typical
things you have here fixed five or six
layers if someone needs seven he can't
do it with that so you have to just
provide something though you can can
change the number of layers and notice i
don't do can you see it this is the same
problem in one of our applications which
is one of the very simple ones but you
see that I it's not interactive now but
you can just add rows here to add layers
and you can just choose from a material
you can define your own materials you
can read the material properties from an
excel file from measurements so you have
a temperature-dependent material data
and all these kinds of things and yet
and the real plot looks not much
different but engineers usually want a
number it's probably not easy to see but
there's a number and the unit so they
know there is in that case that the
radiation heat coming in and that is the
bike by convection there's some heat
amount of heat coming in and there's
something going out and and they can't
just this is some and they just can read
off numbers and that's also something
that the plot is always nice to see and
then it gives you the impression that
what is calculated is ok but it's it's
it's not the full thing and typical
thing is you don't have a single wall
but you have a box with some material
inside and then that six walls so you
you need something that scales you have
no one wall now you have six was there's
also for cool packages and the whole
thing is a
temperature a cool cooling packaging
which is sent around and so at a certain
point you're more involved in managing
your parameters than actually solving
and these off is great and we just push
it to Indies off in the end there is
some code that uses finite volume
methods to generate an area of
differential equations but the real
challenge is to handle all these
parameters in a useful way you choose a
that example is something that we are
wrestling as a product and you can
choose a temperature profile and again
you you just have a tape tabular data I
mean engineers just like the business
people that we have heard in the morning
love table tabular data and and you have
to just provide something that looks a
bit like X and so they get warm with it
and then do you would choose some more
technical things but you don't have to
there's a decent automated parameters I
just want to show you that even this
relatively simple package ends up to the
amount of 2500 equations and then you
solve it in about a minute or so and you
get two temperatures at at various point
in that thing and then the engineer can
can can see whether the product that he
wants to send with that package is
within the admissible temperature range
or not and well there's that's something
that is nice to sell such a product but
it's not of much use to the end user it
just shows that it's really a 3d
calculation of the temperatures it isn't
that thing and then another application
here is in combination with that
temperature package we are using weather
data to
get statistics of what would you expect
first of June to be what were
temperature range would you expect from
the first of june so we use weather data
historic data make some analysis and and
then we can give you the 95 percentile
of certainty that the temperature won't
be more than 30 degrees and from that
you can automatically build a
temperature profile which you can then
calculate with a with a with the other
package and and see what what happens
and if your product is still alive
that's basically what I wanted to tell
you now that the conclusion is can you
use Mathematica for application
development and and I would say yes you
can but you need some to bring some
enthusiasm and and and quite specific
knowledge did you succeed so it's it's
not something that's just with a finger
being a tip and the more interesting
question is is it a good choice and
that's more difficult to answer and I
would say if you can if your topic on
your task may can make a good use of
Mathematica strength and yes it can be a
good good choice but there's again some
small print you should enjoy that all
participants are convinced that it is a
good solution because unfortunately
Mathematica is very easy to it's very
easy to make mathematical look bad if
someone wants he just does something
stupid we all know it's stupid but it
just ends up in Mathematica crushing on
people say it's not good so so you
really need to do to be sure that
everyone agrees on that decision and
then I think you can do very successful
project and you should always expect
when you try to do something like that
that you have to code some stuff
yourself it's not a big problem you're a
developer you should be able to do that
but
you have to do some things yourself that
are kind of off topic for the stuff
you're doing like I wouldn't have
expected me to why to packaging
mechanism and an installer but that some
stuff you usually end up with no thank
you